[Música]
en
1898 marie y pierre curie descubrieron
el radio afirmando que tiene propiedades
curativas añadieron radio a la pasta de
dientes a los medicamentos al agua y a
la comida debido a su color verde
brillante y luminoso también se usó en
productos de belleza y joyas hasta
mediados del siglo 20 no nos dimos
cuenta de que los efectos nocivos del
elemento radioactivo ràdio superaban sus
atractivos visuales
desafortunadamente el radio no es el
único elemento químico que parecía
inofensivo o útil en el pasado como
pigmento resultó ser letal esta
lamentable distinción incluye un trío de
colores y pigmentos que hace mucho que
usamos para embellecer nos y decorar las
cosas que hacemos se trata del blanco el
verde y el naranja nuestra historia
comienza con el blanco ya en el siglo 4
antes de cristo- los antiguos griegos
trataron de obtener del plomo un
brillante pigmento blanco que hoy
conocemos el problema en los seres
humanos el plomo se absorbe directamente
en el cuerpo e invade la sangre los
tejidos blandos y los tejidos
mineralizados una vez que llega al
sistema nervioso
y mitad y altera las funciones normales
del calcio causando daños como problemas
de aprendizaje o presión arterial alta
sin embargo la práctica de usar este
pigmento tóxico continuo a lo largo del
tiempo y de las culturas el plomo blanco
fue la única opción práctica para el
aceite blanco o pintura tempera hasta el
siglo 19 para hacer su pintura los
artistas morían un bloque de plomo en
polvo quedando expuestos a partículas de
polvo altamente tóxicas el uso libre del
pigmento resultó en lo que se conoce
como cólico del pintor o lo que ahora
llamaríamos envenenamiento por plomo los
artistas que trabajaron con el plomo se
quejaron de parálisis melancolía tos
aumento de retina e incluso ceguera pero
la densidad del plomo blanco su opacidad
y el tono caliente fueron irresistibles
para artistas como vermut y más tarde
los impresionistas su resplandor no
podía ser igualado y el pigmento
continuó usando se ampliamente hasta que
fue prohibido en los años 70 por malo
que suene todo esto los efectos nocivos
del plomo no son nada en comparación con
otro pigmento aún más extendido el verde
dos colores verdes sintéticos llamados
el y el verde de parís se introdujeron
por primera vez en el siglo 18 eran
mucho más vibrantes y llamativos que los
verdes relativamente aburridos hechos de
pigmentos naturales así que se
convirtieron rápidamente en dos opciones
populares para la pintura así como tinte
para los textiles el papel pintado el
jabón decoración para postres juguetes
dulces y ropa estos pigmentos verdes se
hacían a base de un compuesto llamado
acepto arsénico de cobre en humanos la
exposición al arsénico puede dañar la
manera en la que las células se
comunican y funcionan y altos niveles de
arsénico se han vinculado directamente
al cáncer y a las enfermedades cardíacas
como resultado los que trabajaban en
fábricas en el siglo 18 sufrían a menudo
de envenenamiento y las mujeres que
llevaban vestidos verdes aparentemente
se desmayaban debido al contacto del
arsénico con su piel se rumoreaba que
los insectos caseros no vivían en
cuartos de color verde e incluso se ha
especulado que napoleón murió por
envenenamiento lento con arsénico por
dormir en su dormitorio decorado con
papel pintado de color verde la gran
toxicidad de estos verdes se mantuvo en
secreto hasta que la receta zen y ccoo
se hizo pública en 1822 y un siglo más
tarde se usaba como insecticida el verde
sintético fue probablemente el color más
peligroso de uso común pero al menos no
compartía la propiedad de radioactividad
del radio no obstante otro color el
naranja sí que era también radioactivo
antes de la segunda guerra mundial era
normal para los fabricantes de vajillas
de cerámica usar el óxido de uranio para
dar color a los esmaltes el compuesto
obtenido al combinar brillantes rojos y
naranjas constituía un atributo
atractivo si no fuera por la radiación
que emitía por supuesto no estuvimos
conscientes de la radiación hasta
finales de 1800 y mucho menos de los
riesgos asociados al cáncer que
descubrimos mucho más tarde durante la
segunda guerra mundial el gobierno de
eeuu confiscó todo el uranio para usarlo
en el desarrollo de bombas sin embargo
la comisión de energía atómica relajó
estas restricciones en 1959 y el uranio
empobrecido fue devuelto a la cerámica y
a la fabricación de suelos de vidrio los
platos color naranja hechos durante la
próxima década pueden aún tener ciertas
cualidades peligrosas en la superficie
hasta el día y más notablemente los
objetos para las fiestas pueden aún dar
positivo en radioactividad y mientras
los niveles son lo suficientemente bajos
para no representar oficialmente un
riesgo para la salud si están en una
estantería el instituto nacional de
estadística de eeuu advierte no comer
alimentos de estos objetos aunque
todavía surgen ocasionalmente con los
colorantes alimentarios sintéticos los
datos científicos nos han ayudado a
eliminar los colores peligrosos de
nuestras vidas si desea más información
sobre la historia oculta del mundo
secretos espaciales preguntas raras
sobre el cuerpo que no desea hacer en
voz alta enigmas sensacionales y mucho
más suscríbase a nuestro canal
manténgase conectado tenga curiosidad